welcome to this video ha bunk never
played him absolutely never get new her
opponents all the time yeah an early g3
yeah that's definitely possible playing
in a very solid manner here against that
b3 ok I am always a bit more afraid of
queen bee three based setups and this in
this kind of position but of course it's
very solid 40 what he plays yes 95 lat
tui 5v5 is a way to provoke a bit of a
weakness here with a 3 let's see if he
just that yes he does um how do I play
this this is a bit awkward the night
down ok let's start with a safe move
it's maybe just coming with with you for
here right it really looks like is
preparing reform
hmm
sure it's not much that I can do about
it I don't know I don't really see a
great constructive museum okay so he
just wants to treat everything off him
okay yeah that's not very exciting yeah
yes this a five pound which gives him
more space and sometimes chances to
attack but this is why I also traded so
many pieces any attack now has to be um
yeah oh it's with with with is happening
with relatively little pieces what is
this okay the only thing going for me is
that is his Queen side is a bit weakish
he really wants to trade everything here
is b6 a move that's interesting maybe he
takes and then I have chances to fight
for the default
this afore look is not coming to before
then yeah I'm not sure about this
decision this could could be quite
interesting to play for me now well
interesting has a strong word you know
at least I have some idea b3 is also a
pawn that I can attack check
rook d3 hero he will play look III wow
that's a that's a strange king and corn
and game she's probably a draw probably
head wrong now roped you three are
taking a five and I win just the pawn
down
this is not totally easy to play for
white maybe g-form yeah okay that's
interesting i have worked before as one
possibility
okay let's start with that and not spend
too much time there i don't know if i
should go f 6 or not f6 difficult to
play without it otherwise i don't get my
king activated ever
hmm
maybe rookie for is a move for him that
could be a drill actually
night isn't I don't think it is I can
take player 5 I think or f5 immediately
is also interesting
takes a 5ef GF takes takes go down check
time warning
just taking twice is using straight away
and here i can take and play age five
maybe King are three holes that's
possible now of course not sorry talking
nonsense I can just take on g4 of course
no no I'm winning basically playing with
an extra pony check
no in-game wasn't so easy to play it was
a little bit passive them you can
certainly draw but well I wasn't it
wasn't totally easy
I know is letting the clock one download
what probably
and the only moment we have to be called
have to be alert as many goes before
that I have to have to take them yeah I
came quite resides chennai interesting
that was interesting yeah i think one
one moment is here here yeah if he is
not taking he doesn't have any kind of
problem it mean he probably has no no
real problem after taking but this is at
least gives me some ideas the double
pawns are not a problem you at all they
make it easier to access the weakness
them okay I mean yes still okay down but
it gets he has to be a little bit a
little bit circumstance circumspect okay
certainly all right up to here six yeah
and now he has to cheat I think just
take it and then can then continue from
from here each that is still the draw of
course I mean this is not a draw i think
unless he has temple mayor's temple
moves fy3 okay sorry i can even play
that I thought if five might be
interesting habit he doesn't have to
play that he can just stay like like
this just shuffle I have no way forward
but this I think is probably losing
check yeah yeah how that is using the
years he has no way out here I'm
threatening to take and i will get i
will get a passer check the time like
here check
I can approach the pawn yeah you can
sometimes post problems due to of with
finding slight imbalances like the
double points here it was a draw but he
has to avoid rookie for at least and he
takes f what's good for the draw I mean
probably hear the I can go in for so but
this is this is a bit bit bit too too
little to to work with okay well thanks
for watching